Officer going down!
Requesting everyone give him
and the perp
some alone time
in this week's Breakdown.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to Edmonton, Alberta,
Canada --
the Great White Trash North.
Home of Prime Minister
Josh Groban.
[ Laughter ]
These two canuck-leheads
got caught using
a stolen credit card.
Isn't everything already free
up there?
I'm not sure how Canada works.
It takes a ride-or-die chick
to mount a Mountie
so her boyfriend
can make a run for it.
Now he's violating
the store's no shirt policy.
Dead end!
Keeping that door locked
is a fire hazard.
He could sue.
There you go.
You're gonna try to bribe
the cop with sunflower seeds.
This might work.
They're very addicting.
[ Laughter ]
I can't hear what he's saying,
but he's a Canadian officer,
so I assume he's apologizing.
Oh, the Taser only
made him stronger.
I'm starting to understand
why American cops
just shoot to kill.
All right, let's check back in
on the tits of the operation.
Hey!
Bathrooms are for
paying customers only.
Women can't go anywhere
without stopping to pee.
Any chance you can hold
your driver's license
up to the camera, you idiot?
[ Laughter ]
We may have a skank infestation
in the attic.
Her escape plans fell through.
Bet she wishes she landed
on a softer aisle.
I guess backup takes
a little longer
when your squad car is a moose.
They got the maximum sentence --
6 months in Winnipeg.
[ Laughs ] That's a local burn.
I'm kidding.
It's just a 2 minute minor,
and for that, we thank you.